I really continue to work on trying to
make the planet more happy this is not
an abstraction for me I got to know too
many people on each side i got to know
too many people to separate the first
time I had an Israeli mother come to me
literally crying and you know holding my
hands bleeding with me to succeed what
does it mean to say that there are
quarks I mean you know science generates
new questions all the time what's a
species the distinctive contribution to
philosophy is to try and be more careful
about the conceptual end of these
questions then most other people have to
be I've got a bit of a so far i can
certainly you know get some of my point
across which is nice i I don't know if
there's points are though my point
attend to all be you know what another
time I was the 14th woman elected
governor in this country and what I hear
from young women in particular is that
they have options today that they might
not have realized they had 20 or 30
years ago now if you could actually
solve the arab-israeli conflict they
would have an impact psychologically
everywhere I would love to be remembered
as the person who didn't answer the
question but who showed us that we were
asking the wrong one you're looking at
the situation through the comic lens
makes these untenable situation okay
it's a place which stands out probably
the Getty Center I see how all the trees
that I planted from how the place is but
sure how it feels like it's been there
for a long time and yet people walking
around looking at everything as though
it's Brad know life is art too if you're
enjoying it helping others to see things
that are new that they didn't seem
before his art all of that is art and
that that's what's fun
you